you sing around the house just call it
and sing do you all ever sing together
um
I feel like your house would be fun yeah
it it yeah I mean Colin
he oh you're being polite I was like
what am I sensing oh that's being polite
College
[Laughter]
so he like things he played um
he does saying he was in
um Fiddler on the Roof like four times
um in high school okay so that's even it
four times yeah why did they do it so
many times exactly do they only get the
rights to the one Musical and they just
kept he also went to like a Catholic
High School so Ultra streams that they
did so many Productions of Fiddler on on
the roof which is that traditionally is
not done with the counseling
does he ever trial jokes on you and then
you're like no
um yes definitely
there's a lot of times where I'm like
it's not now it's just he also like
he'll love um a play on words or a pun
just really Dad joke that have now
become dad jokes they used to be just
like kind of Duds and now they're dads
it's the elevated step up yeah
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]